depuis le mois de février les algériens
sont dans la rue avec un seul mot
d'ordre en finir avec le régime et le
système de bouteflika et jean luc le
gall bout de flèche où le calme à les
généreux ou lloyd des manifestations
dans toute l'algérie
tous les vendredis semaine après semaine
un phénomène inédit
comment expliquer ce réveil de la
population il ya bien eu des tentatives
de rébellion de contestation du système
mais à chaque fois avortés exemple en
2001 avec le printemps noir
nous défions ce pouvoir on encore du
pouvoir
on n'a pas peur des généraux mais ces
manifestations seront cantonnés à la
ville de tizi ouzou en kabylie est
réprimée dans le sang
cent trente personnes tuées selon les
estimations dix ans plus tard printemps
arabe en tunisie le journaliste d'el
watan quotidien algérien francophone
froid alors en une contagion à toute
l'algérie qu'on a des mouvements qui vit
en région dit il en alla de temps très
court en trois jours tout le pays et ont
bravé mais là encore le mouvement sera
avorté par une répression immédiate
la police algérienne a ordre de
disperser tout rassemblement de plus de
10 personnes
c'est l'état d'urgence en vigueur depuis
19 ans en algérie
en 2014 abdelaziz bouteflika à la tête
du pays depuis 1999 se présente pour un
quatrième mandat
la colère monte au sein d'une jeunesse
plombé par le chômage comme ça change
encore plus de liberté plus liberté
d'expression même constat pour les
générations plus anciennes mais la
crainte de revivre les heures noires des
attentats des années 90 freine toute
tentative de rébellion
on aimerait une révolution mais on ne
veut plus que le sont reconnues on veut
juste qu'on nous écoute du sang qui
coule la jeune génération ne l'a pas
connue et cette journaliste en 2014
était plutôt visionnaire
les adolescents et les jeunes adultes
sont plus exigeants que leurs aînés ils
n'ont plus peur ils n'ont pas connu il
est vrai la répression des années 90 une
répression fait au nom de la lutte
contre les islamistes est armé
aujourd'hui ils ne veulent plus de cette
cour cinq ans plus tard en mars 2019 la
jeunesse algérienne a forcé abdelaziz
bouteflika à renoncer à un cinquième
mandat
les manifestants réclament désormais un
changement global de régime
la peur n'est plus dans la mémoire de
cette génération qui osent affronter le
pouvoir en place
[Musique]